okay can we talk about how slow Japanese
businesses were yeah [ __ ] everyone has
this image that Japan's this like super
optimized place optimized system or yeah
you go to a restaurant you press a
button on a tablet and the food just
appears in front of you you know you're
like this is the future and then you and
then you go to a Japanese business and
you like oh is that is that a fax
machine
are you using a fax machine or just like
stuff you never even considered like a
problem or like yeah asking for
permission but like the the slightest
thing on earth like it's just like you
show a logo or something in a video we
gotta find permission to do that so yeah
just [ __ ] upload if it's a problem
don't tell us you know see but like
that's the thing right is that Japan
doesn't understand what well no risk is
war but at least with like what we do
business-wise Japan doesn't have fair
use no yeah so it's so difficult to get
permission for any like if you asked
like like as you said it's like can can
I just show this logo of your company
that is like publicly available to
anybody yeah just like slap it on for
like two seconds I'm not even gonna like
mention your name slap it on it has to
go through like a hundred layers of the
company just to get a simple yes and
that could take like a couple of days if
you're lucky yeah usually a week to
maybe a month and say it's a business
model where there's like imagine if
every employee was a boss and everyone
had to ask for permission yeah it's like
you employees can't make their own
decisions they've to ask their boss who
then asks their boss
and that takes a week and that's just to
see if you can sharpen your pencil right
like we haven't got business yet like
we're just trying to figure out what the
stocks happen it's not even just
business it's just sorry for that it's
everything everything moves so slowly
like I remember when you sign up front
your membership oh my gosh it took us an
hour hour and a half an hour and a half
to sign up for a [ __ ] to get a gym
cut that right cuz you know you know in
um you know in America or like basically
everywhere where you get you get the
terms and conditions right [ __ ] scroll
through you click accepts no in Japan
you're gonna
and you can read every [ __ ] time I
need to agree to every [ __ ] sub
individually I'm not gonna lie gonna sit
there with you to make sure you read it
so yeah you not only a subject to going
through the fine print which is no
longer fine it's like but they like let
me read it out for you in case you're a
[ __ ] a literal piece of [ __ ] it's
like see that's why I like when I signed
up for the gym membership because it's
all written in Japanese right i
straight-up just said like I can read it
I saved myself like an hour of pain of
just like listening to this like [ __ ]
hour long monologue from this like I
think that's cause we're foreign he was
like he he really really wanted to make
sure we understood and better our mind
he's one terms like conditions it were
like any like social things it was like
literally the the bare bones of what a
Jin Jim needs to make sure you know
right like you know don't run on the
treadmill if you know your legs don't
work right like this stuff like don't
basically don't sewers stuff right the
stuff wouldn't take for granted I
remember he was like asking us our
translator like if we understood every
single point Irie one of them is like do
you understand that on the treadmill you
have to have your hands on the treadmill
at all times and I looked at like by our
friend Abbi I was like is he serious
like it's not a joke right yeah that's
me too like it like he legally has to I
have to agree that I'm gonna put my
hands on you have you ever seen it like
anyone bought it like a crippled old man
run on the treadmill one oh yes because
that's how I run like you're signing
this agreement and you turn your head to
see if 10 people on the treadmill none
of them holding their hands and you're
like yeah it's all [ __ ] that's all
you do and this is the stuff that you
never experience as a tourist because
yeah it's like perfectly separate if the
stuff that you experience the toys yeah
- like the stuff you experience living
here and the moment you do something
that is remotely permanent or
reoccurring in a contract you you better
be ready to bring every document that
you've ever had in your life
and the Hanko which you'll lose a lot
I'm surprised they didn't ask for like a
[ __ ] birth certificate when signing
up for the gym because it's so formal we
need to know my life story that's the
perfect word everything in Japan is so
for more and you don't see it as a
tourist cause everything when you hear
in Japan on tourism and you're just
sightseeing everything just works right
your the restaurant it just works living
here all the little intricacies and all
the little things you take for granted
that should be quick yeah just takes a
million processes when it's just the
most unwise thing in the world yeah